Hola Sí qué tal las celebraciones en una
de las tantas esquinas de Buenos Aires
donde bares pone en pantallas para ver
el partido hay varios lugares como este
donde la verdad el entusiasmo ha sido
absoluto un poco de miedo sobre el final
en el segundo tiempo pero también muchos
sustos para Australia porque Argentina
estuvo muy cerca de convertir el tercero
en varias ocasiones Argentina jugó muy
bien que estaba muy contenta la gente
que veía el partido de la performance de
la selección la verdad que enfrentó en
Australia que en el inicio se plantó de
una forma ordenada para tratar de
detener la ofensiva Argentina mantuvo la
cabeza fría jugando la pelota por abajo
qué es lo que también sabe hacer hasta
encontrar los dos huecos primero en el
primer tiempo por parte de del lío Messi
y luego Julián Álvarez en el segundo
tiempo dándole la posibilidad Argentina
después de ese sustazo del gol de
Australia y el potencial segundo gol que
estuvo cerca de Argentina de pasar a
cuartos de final bueno Y usted
precisamente mencionó el gol de Leo
Messi el capitán argentino y quienes sin
duda el centro de atención qué tal va el
10 en este mundial y que él espera la
selección ante Países Bajos
aquí
le canta avanzas a Messi que estaba
jugando su partido número 1000 como
profesional Y está cerca de alcanzar el
récord de récord de goles de selección
nacional Argentina está un gol de
alcanzar ese récord en Argentina jugó
muy bien lío Messi encontrando cada vez
más un rol definido Claro en el equipo
de Argentina por supuesto en la próxima
etapa es un equipo más sólido que el de
Australia por lo menos en los papeles el
de Países Bajos un equipo que llegó
cómodo después del partido de la fecha y
que además en la historia que comparten
en en mundiales hay una paridad a la
historia cambia porque los equipos
también cambian las conformaciones
cambian paso a paso por el entusiasmo es
muy grande